absolutely wonderful stuff uh Bell
Donati there speaking to people who were
trying to meet at the Royal Family ahead
of the coronation this weekend a little
bit of breaking news to bring you now
when it comes to covid-19 because the
World Health Organization has been
meeting today and they have decided to
downgrade covid from a pandemic to an
endemic and that effectively means that
it's no longer considered a global
Health Emergency so a real Milestone
there for the covid-19 pandemic which of
course killed at least seven million
people worldwide just to bring you a
statement from the director General he
said it's with great hope that I declare
covid-19 over as a global Health
Emergency he did go on to say that does
not mean that covid-19 is over as a
global Health threat I have to say uh
given the last few years I'm sure you
watching and also for us as well it does
feel like a real moment that covid-19
being downgraded no longer seen as a
global Health Emergency